good Maureen has everybody doing today
cool
my name is Kavya and today I'm here to
talk to you about data race detection
and more specifically my favorite rese
detector tool the go race detector now
like most of you in this room I think I
write code for a living and like many of
you in this room I think that involves
reasoning about and thinking and
building highly concurrent systems
actually just just real that warm fuzzy
we're all in this together feeling how
many people here are intimately familiar
with the pains and pleasures of
multi-threaded programming about
everybody well that's not surprising in
this day and age multicores power
everything from the i5s on your laptop
to the snapdragons or AAS on your cell
phones
everything's multi-core and we want to
write multi-threaded programs to take
advantage to leverage having these
multiple cores now obviously is the
number of multi-threaded programs being
written has gone up so too has the
number and the frequency of the related
bugs concurrency bugs like data races
and deadlocks now this talk is about the
former it's about data races and just to
make sure we're all on the same page
when I say data race I mean the
situation whereby two threads or two
which maybe userspace threads like Ingo
or system threads when they concurrently
access a shared memory location and one
of those accesses is a right so here's
an example of the of a simple probably
what is the most obvious data Rees
now why is this a data race this is a
data race because there is at least one
order of execution at least one ordering
of the events which results in the wrong
answer in this case for example if G
ones read or G ones write happens before
g 2s read we're good right we get the
right answer we get the expected answer
which is one at the the value of count
at the end of the program
however if they race to read and write
the count variable so they both read
count at the same time and then one
right happens before the other right we
get the wrong answer we get two and in
this case the excesses are concurrent
and this is a data race now this simple
example is going to be a running example
for the rest of the talk
now what's not a data race a race
condition a lot of people it's a common
misconception that data races and race
conditions are the same thing but they
are not the same thing here is an
example of not a data race right because
of the lock the accesses to the count
variable are synchronized
they will never be concurrent however
this is a race condition because if the
if the if your program depends on the
value of count we don't know
deterministically ahead of time whether
the final value of count is 1 or 2 so
this is a race condition so why do we
care about data races well in addition
to being relevant data races are
interesting because they're elusive they
are non-deterministic their timing
dependent and this means they are herds
to write tests for before they happen
and even harder to track down after the
fact and that makes them somewhat
fascinating in addition they have
undefined consequences right if your
program did something wild with the
value of count and the fact that count
had a value of 2 instead of 1 could
result and some really crazy things it's
important to point out that data races
can also result in unexpected
consequences like seg faults or crashes
because the compiler assumes race free
programs and based on that assumption
and makes a number of optimizations so
if your program breaks that rule if
you're a program is not race free then
all bets are off the less feature about
data races that make them interesting is
specific to language Lego and some other
languages like Python which is that it's
almost easy to unintentionally
and unknowingly introduced data races
the goal
map implementation for example in the
standard Lib is not safe for concurrent
access and a lot of new group go
programmers just don't know this so the
obvious question at this point is given
we want to write multi-threaded programs
how can we protect our systems from the
unknown consequences of these difficult
to track down data race bugs in a manner
that's reliable and scalable so the
tried and tested method is tearing
really hard at the code is not an option
it's neither reliable or scalable at the
other extreme protecting every single
memory access with a lock or some sort
of sync primitive is not scalable and
this is where data race detectors come
in swoop in and save the day
these cool cool tools analyze the given
program either statically that is based
on the source code or dynamically as the
program is running and produce a race
report that looks like this this is the
GU race detector output run on our
example racy count program it gives us a
hella lot of information it tells us the
the write and read accesses what lines
they occurred at all sorts of useful
things
now as the developer I can just go in
and like synchronize does that one
access that is racing um so are these
reliable are these tools scalable these
are good questions the answer is
absolutely yes which is why I'm here but
we'll come to the details at the end of
the talk the more interesting question
to me at least is the how is how do
these tools detect both memory accesses
and synchronization events and detect
data races that is the question I will
aim to answer in this talk using the go
race detector as a case study
how many golang developers do we have in
the house all right sweet I can skip
over the basics section then so the go
race detector was
in version 1.1 so it's fairly recent I
y'all must be familiar with it it's
available it's it's available in the
itch tips whip go so it's available as
part of the go tool train you can just
do go build install slash whatever and
pass in the race flag and you get an
example output now the go race detector
is a dynamic race detector and it's
based on a C C++ library called thread
sanitizer that is used widely in Google
if you're familiar with it and the
reason I chose this is my case study is
because it's extremely it's
battle-proven it's found a number of
bugs it's used in industrial used
on-the-go standard library and in google
and it's open source which is nice
alright then let's get started
so the rest of this talk is structured
as follows I will first go over the
fundamentals required the prerequisite
knowledge to understand the detector we
will then dive into the deep deep belly
of the giri's detector will then take a
step back with our understanding and try
and evaluate it and then I'll wrap up
and leave time for Q&A so first things
first and very quickly since most of you
here are familiar with go concurrency
and go is available through goroutines
which are uses space threads and you use
them as you use threads in other
languages now the go memory model is
important to understand because it it
gives us the language guarantees about
our program execution so it says that
all the events executed by a go routine
all the memory access events are
guaranteed to happen in order but if you
have two or more go routines and they
can currently access some shared piece
of data then their access must be
synchronized otherwise all bets are off
so how do you synchronize go routines
you may use channels you may use mutexes
and go also has support for Atomics
which is neat alright so now that we
understand
what we need we have the background
knowledge that we need about go let's
talk about the next core concept
concurrency now if we go back to our
database example we see that one of the
requisites is this concurrent memory
access but how do you determine
concurrent memory accesses with our
simple example alone this is like this
is not an easy answer right if our
program gives us the wrong answer if it
gives us two then we know that that must
have been a data race but there are
other executions possible and now you
think about a larger program and this is
a difficult question so in order to
detect data races we need to be able to
answer the question how can we determine
concurrent memory accesses let's first
think about it intuitively so this is a
similar program to our race account
example - the goroutines is the read and
write of count can that ever be
concurrent no because they are executing
in the same goroutine right we don't
have any goroutines this is single
goroutines so they they cannot be
concurrent accesses ever what about this
example this is again similar to our
racy count example and that we spawn to
goroutines or two threads if you're that
that's the way you think about it except
the sinker the access to the if count
block is synchronized with a lock what
about in this case can a read of count
and a write of count from the two
different go routines ever be concurrent
no again we know the answer in this case
is no because we have a lock what the
lock essentially does is create a
dependency edge of sorts right only one
goroutine can acquire a lock at a time
it must release the lock before the next
go routine can acquire it and since the
right and the read urn
opposite sides of this edge we can we
can conclude that they will never be
concurrent that was easy now in the
literature our intuition about
concurrency is formalized into the
happens before relation don't let the
name scare you it's essentially the same
idea happens before simply gives us a
means to order all the events in our
system which may be memory access events
like reads and writes or synchronization
events like blocks and unlocks across
threads or across go routines so it's
simply it allows us to look at all the
events across threads like across the
entire program and order them now order
both happens before has a few rules in
order to say that one event happens
before the other if you observed their
results as such one of three things must
be true either one they happen in the
same goroutine or two there's
synchronization pair and by that I mean
they are like a lock unlock on the same
mutex object or a send receive on the
same channel or three by transitivity if
we can establish that one event happens
before the other and that event happened
before third then we can conclude that
the first and the third event and the
first event happened before the third
event if we can establish this we're
good but if we can't establish that one
happens before X happens before Y and
what happens before X then Retro their
concurrent let's apply this and make
sure it actually works cuz you know why
would you believe me this is our example
with the mutex with the lock we know
that happens before B because same girl
routine by the lock unlock on the same
object principle we know that B happens
before C and so we can conclude that
a happens before D and this is the same
conclusion we came to intuitively right
we said that the right happens before
the read of the next goroutine what
about if we apply this to our receipt
count example well let's see there are
no edges in this diagram we know that a
happens before B and C happens before D
but what about a and C what about seeing
a there's no edge between them and so we
conclude that they are concurrent
another useful way to visualize happens
before is as a graph if you're if you
think in math we can establish what
happens before path it happens before
relationship if there's a path between
them if not they are concurrent or we
get so far cool so now that we know that
for data races we need to determine
concurrency and we're going to determine
concurrency but happens before the next
obvious question is well how do you
implement how do you implement happens
before and again for this we turn to the
literature and the literature says use
vector clocks our folks here familiar
with vector clocks okay so so okay so
don't let the name scare you the
concepts pretty simple the idea behind
vector clocks is each actor in your
system each go routine or each thread
has its own vector clock and the vector
clock is simply an array of n clocks
where n is the number of threads or
goroutines so we'll work through an
example quickly and each clock
corresponds to one go routine right and
these aren't clocks in the sense of time
stamps you they're logical clocks or
scalar clocks you can think of them as
versions there's certain update rules
and to understand this let's just walk
through an example so these are the
vector clocks of our to go
Jeanne's this uses the count with a lock
example now at the beginning of the
world both of them add a vector clocks
are initialized to 0
now at each event a goroutine is going
to update its index in its vector clock
it's going to incremented by 1 so at the
lock this becomes 1 0 at the read this
becomes 2 0 at the right this becomes 3
0 and then there's an unlock and this
becomes 4 0 now the unlock is a special
event because it's an event that it's a
synchronization event it's going to
establish a happens before an edge so at
this point we call this like we call
this a send event because this is an
unlock once it unlocks it it can send
though the mutex over and at this point
it sends conceptually it sends its
vector clock over as well now goroutine
2 can receive the it can receive the
mutex so it sees one event and
increments its vector clock by 1 and
again since this is a special
synchronization event a received
synchronization event it performs the
special update it takes the max of every
element in the vector clock and updates
its value its entire vector clock to
that to that max so from 0 1 this
becomes 4 1 does that make sense
cool so vector clocks are supposed to
help us determine concurrency let's see
how that happens
so applied to our program 0 0 first
event second event third event fourth
event is the unlock so it's going to
send it over now this point goroutine 2
has an event and so it's vector clock is
4 1 and its second event
now our question is does a happen before
D and the answer is if is vector clock
is less than DS vector clock they happen
before each other it happens before D is
that true here well 3 is less than 4 0
is less than 2 so yes they happen before
each other now let's apply it to a
different example a more complicated
example here we've introduced a third go
routine and we're going to establish a
happens before edge between goroutine 1
and 3 so it's going to send something
over with that send it's going to send
its vector clock over to and our
question is is D does D happen before F
what do you think no right so we're
going to compare their vector clocks and
we see that every element in D is not
less than every element in F so they
don't happen before each other what
about F happens before D for the same
reason F does not happen before D and
since they don't happen before each
other this is a concurrent access so at
this point you're probably thinking well
cool Kavya now I know all about happens
before in vector clocks but why didn't
we just go back to grad school and the
answer is because this is what the girl
race detector does it determines if two
memory accesses are concurrent by a by
establishing this happens before
relationship and to do that it uses
vector clocks this method of race
detection is called a pure happens
before detection there are other types
of detection but this is the one we'll
talk about today all right everybody
with me so far
cool
it is now time to dive into the deep
deep belly of the go race detector and
look at how it's implemented so in order
to implement happens before using bec
two clocks
what would the go race detector need to
do well let's see it will have to create
vector clocks for goroutines at
goroutine creation it will then have to
update these vector clocks at each
memory access and synchronization events
and then at each memory access event it
has to compare these vector clocks to
decide if there's a data race now if you
stare really hard at these bullet points
and maybe the coloring will give you a
hint you will see that we can
essentially tease out two subproblems a
problem of event generation and a
problem if event consumption and we're
going to make it the program's
responsibility to handle the event
generation in that every time the event
every time the program performs a
goroutine creation or a memory access
it's going to report it and the race
detector is simply going to consume
these events and take care of updating
its state it's going to create the
vector clocks it's going to update the
vector clocks it's going to take care of
all of that at a high level this is how
the go race detector is implemented its
implemented conceptually as a state
machine whereby the program as it's
running generates events and the vector
the race detector keeps program state
vector clocks etc and it updates them
based on the events it receives but
problem does this mean that we have to
modify our programs so at every memory
access at every synchronization every
goroutine creation do we have to call
out to the race detector do we have to
modify our programs well no we just saw
that we can take our program and run the
detector on it so what's going on to
answer that question let's look at the
source
so this is our racy count program
compiled without the race without race
detection enabled this is what the
assembly for the increment count
function alone looks like and this is
uninteresting this looks pretty standard
the function is defined now if we
compile the program with race detection
enabled what is the output of that look
like well for one it looks longer but
there's something else there a number of
extra calls inserted there is a race
func enter there's a race read a race
right what's happened is that the go
compiler the GC compiler has essentially
transformed our program to look like
this whoops
to look like this right it's inserted
the calls out to the race detective for
us now the way the compiler does this is
pretty standard so I'm not going to go
over the details the idea is that if
race detection is enabled it adds an
extra instrumentation pass over the ir
so it essentially modifies the code tree
generated well this is awesome it means
that we don't have to modify our
programs to track memory accesses well
what about synchronization events and
goroutine creation for that let's look
at the source of the ghost standard
library this is mutex go this gives us
the mutex sync primitive and we see that
there is an if race enabled block which
essentially calls out to erase the
Tector function Reese acquire similarly
goroutines are created in proc go write
the new proc one function is what's
responsible for creating a new Gore
from the ghost standard library and we
see the same if race enabled block with
a function call add to the grease
detector cool so what did these race
detective what do these functions do for
that let's go to the fiercest and see
what's going on well ignore the fact
that it's an assembly file we can talk
about it later but what we notice is
that there's a call to T San read this
is a call to the thread sanitizer
library the C C++ race detection library
that we talked about the goriest
detector isn't just based on TCM it's
literally built on T standard calls into
T San so at this point we know two
things we know that one the program can
generate these events for us thanks to
compiler instrumentation and the ghost
standard lib and we know that the race
detector the the magic sauce that takes
care of all the state is T San so how
does T San work well T San implements
the happens before detection so what
does it need to do if we go back to our
checklist we see that it has to do
something with vector clocks right and
to do this it uses something called
thread state it needs to compute these
happen before edges and to do that it
uses those two data structures and
finally it needs to compare vector
clocks to detect data races rather than
talking about the details let's just
look at an example so this is our
program and we'll see what T San does at
each step so the first call to spawn a
goroutine
go increment count results in a call out
to t san as we saw and at this point t
san creates this thread state now thread
state simply
contains the vector clock for that
goroutine and it returns it to the
program so it can be stored on the
goroutine alright so check we have a
vector clock for our goal routine now
we're going to do we're going to perform
a read we're going to check count equal
to zero now at this point T sound has to
do two things it has to check if there's
a data race with the previous access and
if there isn't it has to stir
information about this access for future
detections let's look at two first to do
this TCN uses something called shadow
State it essentially creates a shadow
word to track each memory access and
this stores information about the access
like this like the thread ID the clock
the position like where the access
occurred and whether the access was a
read or write now these the shadow State
is directly mapped the details don't
matter now teason performs two
optimizations to the shadow State the
first is rather than storing one per
memory access because that would just
consume a lot of memory it stores a a
fixed number of Shetty's shadow cells in
the current implementation it's for for
a region of memory let's just see how
that works so if there is a read to the
first two bytes of an applications word
this is the this is the shadow word
created now if another goroutine comes
along and writes to the last four bytes
this is the next shadow word created
does this make sense cool
the second optimization is that teason
does not store the entire vector clock
it only stores the scalar clock which is
the accessors index in its vector clock
now these two optimizations may seem
surprising you know doesn't it caused a
loss in percent
in procession it turns out to not matter
as we will see so going back to our
program so the dog the read of count
translates to the creation of this
shadow word right we have it's the
thread ID we have its clock which is
zero we have the the region red and we
have a zero because it was a read now at
the count
there is another shadow word created
that looks like this and here's where it
gets interesting
g2 comes along and g2 performs a read
and this is what its shadow word looks
like right that's G 2 0 0 8 M 0 at this
point T sounds going to check if there's
a Reese let's let's see how that's done
ok the algorithm at this point is really
is beautifully simple all you have to do
is check the accessors vector clock that
is the full vector clock and the new
shadow word with the existing shadow
word let's see how this works so what
exactly are we checking for one do the
do the access locations overlap right
are they reading if shared oh sorry
are they accessing a shared memory
location yes they are are any of these
accesses are right why yes they are are
the T IDs different are these two
different goroutines why yes they are
and lastly can we establish a happens
before edge between them well let's see
we're going to use vector clocks right
that's why we learned about them so
we're going to take G to Ector clock and
compare it to the existing shadow words
clock in order to decide that the read
happened before the right we
the shadow words vector clock to be less
than the g20 clock right is that true in
this case well no it's not well for red
checkmarks what could that possibly mean
it's a race so this point we've seen how
T San implements race detection this was
the simplest example there are obviously
other there there's obviously a lot more
T sans this hell a huge C++ library but
a few a few important notes first T San
obviously must track synchronization
events as well right now these events
are important because they establish
that happens before edges and in order
to facilitate that transfer that
exchange of vector clocks T San uses
like a sinc var which is another data
structure but the interesting thing
about this data structure is its stores
of vector clock as well so when a sender
and receiver manipulate is the vector
clock is effectively transferred over
the other points note is that T sin
tracks file descriptor memory allocators
and all of that the goal of this being
that it is able to recognize implicitly
synchronized events to so not just
explicitly by a walk of art channel but
implicit synchronizations that may
happen through file descriptors the t
san recognizes that the goal of this is
so it doesn't report false positives
speaking of false positives let's
quickly answer our remaining two
questions we know how the how it works
but we still want to know is it reliable
is t s-- is the girl race detector via t
san scalable
well first question well
season or the giri's detector does not
report false positives so if it reports
a race there is a data race there is
some order of events in your program
that would result in a database but just
because it reports a data race it
doesn't mean that it's dangerous right
there is such a thing as benign data
races and that's up to you as the
programmer to decide though the
consequences of the data race it can
miss races though and this is important
this is a property of dynamic race
detectors that they depend on the
particular execution the particular
execution of the program that you run
them on right so for example if we ran
our example program an enough number of
times there would be at least one
execution where there wouldn't be a data
race and in that case the race detector
wouldn reporter 'yes so depends on the
actual events that occur and is it
reliable well yes it's battle-proven
like we said Google LLVM there are a
number of users out there a second
question is it's scalable oh not really
this is the program slowed down at the
execution time and that is the memory
usage overhead of using the go race
detector but is it scalable with
respects to finding data races well it's
more scalable than staring at your giant
codebase and it's certainly more
scalable with respects to your programs
performance than locking everything and
shipping that to production the
recommended use of the go race detector
is in E is in your testing environment
or on your staging environment or even
like a production cannery box and it
works well for those persons for those
purposes alright that brings us to the
end of the talk thank you all for coming
as you leave today I hope you walk away
with an appreciation for the fascinating
nature of the race detection the data
Ruiz detection problem and I hope you
learned about happens before and happens
before using vector clocks and I hope
you've learned about the the go race
detector and how that works by compiler
instrumentation and this hella cool T
San runtime library thank you
we have about five minutes for questions
yes
yes
right so I rushed over the optimization
sections we can go back to that yeah
that's a great question so the so this
is the simple scheme right where you
store one shadow word per memory acts
and per memory location per access and
we you can see how that would work but
the optimization that teason performs is
foreign applications for 8 bytes of the
application so for a word in a 64-bit
but for an entire word it's tracked only
for accesses to that entire region are
tracked ok and you might think if you
throw if you only keep the last four
accesses and evicts accesses this might
affect precision and that's true right
but the race detective doesn't claim to
not report it doesn't claim to be like
foolproof right yeah so that's okay now
let's see how this actually works so say
that there's an access a read access to
those two bytes this is the shadow word
created and we know that it's dos two
bytes that were accessed because of the
position and the offset which says 0 to
know if there's another access to this
region of memory like a write of the
last four bytes that that index is 4 8
so we know that it was to a different
region yeah if there was a if there was
another region like if there was another
block that would be tracked by another
set of 4 yes that's right and these the
shadow state is stored in whoops
yeah no it's not forever it's for per
eight bytes of the application Thanks
thanks that's a good question let me
pull up
yes yeah so an alternative to dynamic
race detection is static race detection
right so instead of this instead of
grease detection the race detector
analyzed the program source and the the
advantage of this is that only a single
pass of the program is required and and
and that single pass should report all
races and so it ends up it ends up being
more effective in that sense but the
problem with it is that you have to
change your source code of infrasonic
race detection you'd have to add these
annotations to call out to the race
detector and that's obviously for a
larger code bases that's not that's not
something that they'd want to do with
respect to the potential for it in a
language like oh well I don't know if a
good reason why it hasn't been
implemented I think the reason that the
go race detector is is what it is is
because go happen like go was created at
Google and T San was widely used at
Google so at the time it came down to
choosing a race detector I believe that
was like one of the leading factors in
the decision
mm-hmm yeah
any other questions
yes so tea Sam
so Tisa and requires like help from the
compiler to run right so the GCC
compiler and go so go has two compilers
the GCC compiler and the GCC go compiler
it's not supported by GCC go but the GCC
compiler supports this in addition you
can also use T San with the later
versions of are not late anymore but
with certain versions of LLVM LLVM is
clang and with GCC and that you would
use that for race detection in C C++
yes
yes yeah yeah it's pretty cool
the other neat thing about tea Sam is
that it allows it recognizes your
customs synchronization primitive via
dynamic annotations so if you created
your own class or like your own object
and you wanted that's to behave like a
synchronization primitive in that you
wanted that to establish these happens
before edges and not report data races
on that you can arrange for tea sand to
do that by dynamic annotations which is
yeah you're probably kid yeah yeah I
think so yeah
though so this comes back to like
happens before right in order to get a
partial ordering over all the events
across goroutines you you must be able
to recognize those edges because that
that's what establishes the ordering
yes yeah exactly it's to Trent it's to
facilitate that exchange of vector
clocks because what needs to happen is
when there's a synchronization event
Tisa needs to update the thread states
right to the vector clock stored in the
thread states to reflect the fact that
that was a synchronization event yes
oh I have not because its proprietary
you can't get access to it or I would
have used it I see sorry I should be
doing this the question was how does
this compare to the Intel Intel has a
race detector what what is it called
it's called system studio or something
like that but the question was how does
the go race detector compared to the
Intel race detector and I believe it
does something by injecting I see okay
nice cool alright thank you I believe
lunch is outside